Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism
episode is brought to you by Vimeo pro,
which is the ideal video hosting platform for entrepreneurs and in fact a bunch
of my startups already use Vimeo pro including wealth front who uses it to
explain how wealth front works task grab,
it uses it to tell the company story and there are many other names you would
recognize among their customers,
airbnb,
Etsy,
et cetera.
Why do they use it?
Well,
Vimeo pro provides enterprise level video hosting for a fraction of the usual
cost.
Features include gorgeous high quality playback with no ads,
up to 20 gigabytes of video storage every week.
Unlimited plays in views and a fully customizable video player,
which can include your logo,
custom outro,
et cetera.
You also get VIP support and you get all of this for just one 99 per year.
That's $17 a month with no complicated bandwidth calculations or hidden fees,
and you can try it risk free for 30 days.
So check it out.
vimeo.com forward slash business.
That's vim,
e o.com forward slash business and use Promo Code Tim to get 25% off.
That's a special discount just for you guys.
So check it out.
vimeo.com forward slash business Promo Code Tim,
this episode is brought to you by Wealthfront and this is a very unique sponsor.
Wealthfront is a massively disruptive in a good way,
set it and forget it.
Investing service led by technologists from places like apple and world famous
investors.
It has exploded in popularity in the last two years and they now have more than
two and a half billion dollars under management.
In fact,
some of my very good friends,
investors in silicon valley have millions of their own money in Wealthfront.
So the question is why?
Why is it so popular?
Why is it unique?
Because you can get services previously reserved for the ultra wealthy,
but only pay pennies on the dollar for them.
And this is because they use smarter software instead of retail locations,
bloated sales teams,
et cetera.
And I'll come back to that in a second.
I suggest you check out wealthfront.com forward slash Tim take the risk
assessment quiz which only takes two to five minutes and they'll show you for
free exactly the portfolio they'd put you in and if you just want to take their
advice,
run with it,
do it yourself.
You can do that or as I would,
you can set it and forget it and here's why.
The value of Wealthfront is in the automation of habits and strategies that
investors should be using on a regular basis but normally aren't great investing
is a marathon,
not a sprint,
and little things that you may or may not be familiar with like automatic tax
loss harvesting,
rebalancing your portfolio,
cross more than 10 asset classes and dividend reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods of time.
Wealthfront,
as I mentioned,
since it's using software instead of retail locations,
etc. Can offer all of this low costs that were previously completely impossible
right off the bat,
you never pay commissions or account fees for everything.
They charge 0.25% per year on assets above the first 15,000 which is managed for
free.
If you use my link,
wealthfront.com forward slash Tim,
that is less than $5 a month to invest a $30,000 account for instance.
Now,
normally when I have a sponsor on this show,
it's because I use them and recommend them.
In this case,
it's a little different.
I don't use Wealthfront yet because I'm not allowed to.
Here's the deal.
They wanted to sponsor this podcast,
but because of sec regulations,
companies that invest your money are not allowed to use client testimonials.
So I couldn't be a user end have them on the podcast,
but I've been so impressed by Wealthfront that I've invested a significant
amount of my own money,
at least for me,
uh,
in the team and the company itself.
So I am an investor and hope to soon use it as a client.
Now back to the recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show listener,
you'll get $15,000 managed for free if you decide to open an account.
But just start with seeing the portfolio that they would suggest for you.
Take two minutes,
fill out their questionnaire@wealthfront.com forward slash.
Tim.
It's fast.
It's free.
There's no downside that I can think of.
Now,
I do have to read a mandatory disclaimer.
Wealthfront Inc is an SEC registered investment advisor.
Investing in securities involves risks and there's the possibility of losing
money.
Past performance is no guarantee of future results.
Please visit wealthfront.com to read their full disclosure,
so check it out.
Guys.
This is one of the hottest,
most innovative companies coming out of Silicon Valley and they're killing it.
They've become massively popular.
Just take a look,
see what portfolio they would create for you,
and you can use that information however you want.
wealthfront.com forward slash Tim.
Hello my friends,
you muscularly Oompaloompas.
Welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss show.
My name is Tim Ferriss and my job is to deconstruct world class performers,
people who are the best at what they do,
and to tease out the habits,
routines,
findings that you can apply to your own life,
whether they are people like Arnold Schwarzenegger,
chess prodigies like Josh Waitzkin,
directors like Jon Favreau or Robert Rodriguez and hedge fund managers,
military strategists,
everyone in between today we have a researcher,
doctor Bernay Brown and you can say hi to her on Twitter at Bernay Brown is a
research professor at the University of Houston Graduate School of Social Work
and her 2010 Tedx talk.
The power of vulnerability has more than 20 million views.
It is one of the top five most viewed ted talks in the world,
which is very hard to pull off.
She has other talks with millions and millions of views,
so once you're lucky twice,
you're good.
She is very good.
She has spent the past 13 years studying vulnerability,
courage,
worthiness and shame.
All of my favorites Bernays,
the author of two Number One New York Times bestsellers,
daring greatly and the gifts of imperfection.
Her new book is titled Rising Strong and in it she writes,
if we are brave enough,
often enough,
we will fall.
This is a book about what it takes to get back up.
And she interviews some very interesting folks,
top performers in the corporate world,
startup world,
military world and the gathers data to support the recommendations and
conclusions in these books.
So I have a copy of rising strong and encourage you to check it out.
She's also the founder and CEO for the daring way,
which is an organization that brings her work to organizations,
schools,
communities and families.
And without further ado,
I want to let you enjoy this wide ranging conversation that touches on some
sensitive topics you might say with doctor Bernay Brown.
Bernay welcome to the show.
Thank you.
I'm excited to talk to you
and my fans are excited to hear all of your wisdom and dig into your research.
Uh,
and I suppose we could,
we could start with some context for those people who are not familiar with your
work.
When you were asked the question,
what do you do?
How do you answer that?
It really,
I actually have two answers I want,
if I want to keep talking,
then one,
if I doubt it.
So if I don't want to keep talking,
I'm usually will just say I'm ashamed.
Researcher.
And that scares people.
And then they usually go on.
They usually say,
so what do you think about the Texans this season or something?
Um,
and then if I'm in a normal conversation,
I'll say that I studied vulnerability and courage,
shame and worthiness.
And
that's,
that's kind of terrible,
isn't it?
But I do that.
I don't think it's terrible.
I think that you can do kind of a reverse George Castanza when you don't want to
talk to someone if you're trapped on a planet or something.
So instead of saying,
you know,
picking the most interesting thing to get them to admire you and say you're an
architect,
you can be like,
Oh yes,
no,
I'm a,
you know,
you could bring up something extremely awkward,
right?
Like I,
you know,
I research,
uh,
you know,
off color,
sex trafficking or something,
and then depending on who you're sitting next to,
I suppose it could be a good character check.
Right.
Okay.
It's a totally,
it's a total character shot.
Did they watch it after they hear I said he's shame.
Um,
then that kind of bites me on the ass a little bit,
but it's works pretty well.
You're
like,
you're not following the script pal.
You're at your office.
Uh,
so,
so speaking of script and,
uh,
I am not the only one who's been impressed with your presenting ability,
but it seems like one of the ways that you really hit the mainstream map was
through Ted and,
uh,
specifically I guess it would have been the,
the power of vulnerability,
although that,
that has more than 21 million views now.
And,
uh,
some of your other presentations have more than 5 million views.
So certainly,
uh,
you know,
once you're lucky twice,
you're good.
You're good at this.
Uh,
could you give people an of the components that make a hit speech or Ted talk
because you're,
you're clearly good at it.
It's not a one hit wonder.
How did the power of vulnerability come to be?
How did you decide on the,
on that,
on the content and rehearse it and so on?
Just the,
the,
the genesis story I think would be very interesting.
Um,
yeah,
I'd love this year cause it's been a,
a huge learning for me.
So the Tedx talk was kind of a combination of an accident and an experiment.
Um,
the curators of Tedx Houston asked me to open their first event,
um,
and they called and they were really excited and I asked,
I said,
sure,
I'd love chair.
I was really excited.
Um,
and they have their for dual is the curator.
And I said,
what do you want me to talk about?
And you know,
when you study things like shame and vulnerability,
people can get very prescriptive about what they want you to say and what they
don't want you to say.
Um,
and it really has no bearing,
actually are what I do say.
But they like to think in the beginning that they're going to control some of
that.
And so I said,
you know,
do you have any thoughts?
And his answer was B,
awesome.
Have Fun.
And the day before the yeah,
which is you would think it's liberating and,
but it's also kind of terrifying.
Right?
And so yeah,
the curse of no constraints.
Exactly.
And so I was on a flight home the night before,
a long flight with my husband and kids and I looked at Steve and I was like,
I think I'm going to experiment tomorrow.
And my husband looked at me and he said,
that sounds like a terrible idea.
And I said,
yeah.
no,
I think I'm going to actually be really vulnerable while I'm talking about
vulnerability.
And he said,
you know,
again,
not sure that's a great idea.
So I went to the Ted Event and I experimented.
I really kind of put myself out there.
I talked about my own breakdown,
spiritual mean,
I talked about having to go to therapy and how much I really hated that.
And I kind of thought it was bullshit,
but like I had to do it and I really put myself out there and I remember driving
home and thinking,
I will never do that again.
I mean,
I literally had,
I literally had what I thought was one of the worst vulnerability hangovers of
my career.
Okay.
And I was so grateful,
you know,
I have to tell you to,
I was so grateful that there were only 500 people there and that it was recorded
at University of Houston where I've taught for 20 years.
So most people kind of are like,
oh yeah,
that's Bernay I don't have any memory of that being recorded.
And I,
and I'm pretty,
I'm pretty sure maybe the universalist aligned and thought,
you know,
let's not let her know that this is being recorded.
So when it came out on the Tedx,
you know,
on the Tedx side,
I was pretty mortified.
Steve's,
you know,
it seems like no one's gonna Watch it,
don't worry.
And then several months later,
Chris Anderson called and said,
okay,
hey,
we're,
we don't usually put the tedx talks that,
but we really,
we love your talking.
We want to put it that,
and I,
I think the conversation like this,
which is an interesting form of leadership,
I think I said,
no,
uh,
I'm flattered,
but no thank you.
And he said,
I think December 23rd will be great.
And then that was that.
And so it went up on December 23rd and against.
He was like,
don't worry Renee,
I don't think that you people are not going to see it.
And it went like one to 1 million,
1 million,
one,
3 million.
And I was like,
oh.
And so if I look back,
so my learning,
my takeaway from that experience was this,
if I'm not a little bit nauseous,
what I'm done,
I probably did not show up like I should have shown up.
That's great.
That's,
that's uh,
that's,
that echoes advice from,
I believe it's Neil Gaiman in the commencement speech make good art where you
talked about,
you know,
when you feel like you're walking down the street naked and extremely
uncomfortable,
maybe you're starting to get it right.
I'm paraphrasing of course.
But that's a,
that's a really good,
uh,
that's really good point.
How did you,
I mean,
your delivery was so spot on.
How did you rehearse a,
or did you,
I mean,
maybe you're just,
uh,
maybe that is a language that you're naturally fluent in presentation that is,
but,
uh,
how did you prep for it?
I don't rehearse at all.
In fact,
she rehearsing is really,
so when I rehearse and the traditional way we think about rehearsing,
it's about what I'm going to say and what I'm going to say it and how I'm going
to say it.
And so if I do that,
what ends up happening?
I've tried a couple of times.
I get,
so like prefrontal Cortex,
I get so
wrapped up and oh it,
I supposed to pause here and wasn't I supposed to do this there that I am not,
I'm not connecting.
And so for me it is use images as the arc,
understand what image every image means to me and what I want to wrap around
that image and then require that the house lights are on so I can see people's
faces.
That's a good role.
That's a really good role.
Yeah.
So that thing where they're,
you know,
and I rarely,
rarely allow any of my presentations to be videotaped.
Um,
very,
very rarely because one,
if they're taping you,
you have to be super hot under the lights and the audience has to be dark and
then its performance,
not connection for me.
Um,
and then secondly,
I don't feel like it's anyone's business,
what happens between me and an audience at given moment.
I mean,
I just really feel like that's an a,
that's a moment.
Yeah.
And I think that comes,
I mean I'm speculating here,
but from a lot of experience teaching,
right?
Being in,
in front of students as opposed to viewing yourself as being in front of an
audience,
uh,
which,
which I think enables a very different relationship with the people you're
trying to communicate to or communicate with.
Andy did to provide perhaps a little bit of connective tissue for people who are
curious about your research.
Um,
the,
you mentioned vulnerability mentioned shame.
Uh,
how should we define these terms just for the purposes of this conversation and
so people can understand and how did you research them?
Yeah,
I think the best place to start when we're talking about kind of what words
mean,
at least the way I use them in my work is to really start with vulnerability.
Um,
if I think if you can get your head and heart wrapped about around
vulnerability,
the others make a lot more sense.
Um,
so to me,
I don't know how you were raised and how the listeners were raised,
but I was raised to believe that vulnerability is weakness.
Um,
that you wake up in the morning,
you armor up,
you go out into the day,
you kick some ass and you don't let people see your emotions.
You mitigate uncertainty and risk as much as you can and that's the way you
live.
And so from the very earliest stages of my research,
you know,
13 years ago,
that is not how vulnerability emerged in the data.
Um,
vulnerability emerged as not weakness,
but probably our best measure of courage.
So when we asked people,
you know,
what is vulnerability?
They would say things like,
it's the first date after my divorce.
It's trying to get pregnant after my second miscarriage.
It's sitting with my wife who has stage four breast cancer and making plans for
our three year old and five year old.
It's starting my own business is taking my business public.
It's getting fired,
it's firing someone.
Um,
it's getting promoted,
it's missing the promotion.
And so it came,
it became very clear to me early on that the simplest definition for
vulnerability is really uncertainty,
risk and emotional exposure.
Vulnerability is about the willingness to show up and be seen when you have zero
control over the outcome.
And
I think if you ask people to close their eyes and think about the last time they
saw someone doing something truly brave,
it is very easy to see how vulnerability underpins all acts of courage.
Sure.
And yeah,
I mean I just think it's about really
okay.
It's about putting yourself out there and which is increasingly difficult to do
in this very hypercritical and forgiving kind of media culture.
And so vulnerability is showing up and being seen.
Um,
courage to me,
you know,
I love the word courage because the root of the word is Kerr and the Latin for
careers heart.
And when courage first came into the English language,
the original definition was to tell the story of your,
of who you are with your whole heart.
That was an act of courage.
Um,
so to me,
courage is really about choosing what's right over what's easy,
practicing your values,
not just professing them and choosing to be brave over being comfortable.
And these,
I love this type of
contextual cut prelude.
It's not a prelude,
but it's a defining,
because I think it's so important for any important conversation.
And certainly I think for most conversations to make sure that the people in the
conversation or talking about the same thing,
right?
Yeah.
It's the key to everything.
Right?
Right.
Yeah.
And that starts with defining very,
very end.
I've noticed,
for instance,
even in my own relationships,
something as seemingly clear as honesty,
I want you to be honest,
say an intimate relationships are actually can,
can have a,
you had a,
no pun or Noah illusion intended,
but you know,
50 shades of grey,
right?
If there are,
it can mean something very different.
You know,
is is a mission a lie or are we talking about a misrepresentation of truth?
Right.
And,
uh,
it's,
it's really critical.
And I like your description because,
you know,
courage.
I remember thinking when you were,
when you were walking us through this,
uh,
custom auto,
who was Mike Tyson's primary trainer who,
who,
uh,
who brought him to the pinnacle of his success,
with tell Mike who was terrified before going into the ring.
Uh,
in the dressing room and so on that,
you know,
the hero and the coward feel the same thing.
It's how the,
how it's how the hero responds that makes them different.
And you know,
the,
you can't be courageous unless you are exposing yourself to a perceived risk,
which by definition makes you vulnerable even if you're thinking about it in a
very literal kind of physical sense.
So the,
the,
uh,
I'd love to segue too to shame because I was reading,
one of,
uh,
your alumni publications,
and you can correct this certainly if it's not accurate,
but a quote of yours came up that I thought was really insightful and worth
exploring bit.
And it's a shame.
Hates to have words wrapped around it.
If we talk about it,
it loses its grip on us.
And I was hoping maybe we could,
uh,
you could elaborate on that and,
help us to,
to then understand shame.
Yeah.
And I think that that quote is so powerful because it's so true.
Like I often when I talk about shame,
I often like to personify it and say,
you know,
shame is a very formidable foe.
You know,
shame is this intensely painful belief or experience that something is wrong
with us,
that we are flawed and that we're unworthy of love and belonging and we all know
it.
Everyone knows that warm wash that comes over you that makes you feel like
you're not enough.
Um,
we have 50 years of data that really show us in my mind and questionably that
the only people who don't experience shame are people who don't have a capacity
for connection.
Who?
People who don't have a capacity for empathy.
So if we are capable of having connection,
we know shame because shame is the fear that we're not worthy of connection.
And so
the thing about shame that makes it so difficult is it needs three things to
thrive in our lives.
If you've take a petri dish and you put shame in a petri dish and you Dallas it
with secrecy,
silence and judgment,
it grows exponentially.
It will,
it will grow into every corner and crevice of our lives.
If you have the same amount of shame and a petri dish and you Dallas it with
empathy,
shame can't survive.
Empathy.
Empathy is a very hostile environment for shame.
And so to understand shame,
I think what resonates mostly with people are the two kinds of tapes that shame
drives.
The first is you're not enough and you can fill in the blank.
You're not thin enough,
pretty enough,
strong enough,
powerful enough,
rich enough or good enough,
loved enough,
awesome enough,
you're not enough.
Um,
and then if we can somehow get a handle on that and say,
you know,
like,
okay,
I've got,
you know,
I have this big presentation and you've got the shame Gremlin and your ear
saying,
you're not enough.
You're not smart enough.
They're going to be like a hundred Mbas and that ran,
what do you know about business?
You're not enough.
If you can Russell that thing down.
The other tape that shame drives is who do you think you are?
Um,
so it creates this amazing vice that our self worth gets caught in,
um,
and just squeezes us from both sides.
And so shame and shame is really visceral.
I mean,
if you,
if you just say the word to people,
people can feel
no,
definitely.
And you mentioned you to fear of disconnection.
I mean,
I wrote down when I was doing some research before this call,
you know,
being shunned.
Question Mark.
And,
uh,
I'd love to ask you because a question that came from some of my listeners was,
what is the evolutionary need of shame or,
or why did that develop in human beings?
And it seems to be like shame,
Ken,
serve a useful purpose,
right?
If you are ashamed of the fact that you think about molesting a child that sees,
that serves a societal function,
right?
Uh,
so you had are,
you know.
Okay.
All right.
Well,
I'd love for you to expand on that because,
uh,
I,
that's,
uh,
I,
that's an interesting viewpoint.
So could you,
could you expand on that?
If you look at shame from an evolutionary biological perspective,
um,
I think it did absolutely serve a function.
So 10,
you lead the dinosaur back to the K,
it eats my entire family and my whole clan.
This is the second time you've done that.
So we are literally going to shun you from our collective,
which means you'll be alone,
which means death.
Right?
And so because you're dangerous,
uh,
I'm just not,
not unlike if we see even in the animal world today,
some pack animals,
if there's a sick animal among them will literally,
you know,
approach it as a group and back it off a cliff,
um,
for the sake of the pack.
Right?
So,
so that makes sense.
As we've evolved,
um,
as we've evolved neuro biologically as we evolved,
shame becomes a very profoundly dangerous tool,
um,
for people who have the emotional understanding that we had.
So now what we see is you can change a behavior sometimes,
especially with children on a dime with shame,
but it's like hitting a thumbtack with a 500 pound anvil,
you are going to crush that thumbtack and the process of doing that.
Um,
so what we see now is we see shame,
highly,
highly correlated with addiction,
depression,
aggression,
violence,
suicide.
Eating disorders very highly correlated.
MMM.
What we see as the inverse is we see guilt
and shame and guilt are very different.
Shame is I am a bad person.
Guilt is I did something bad so you go out on Thursday night,
you get wasted.
You're so hungover on Friday,
you sleep through your alarm clock,
you miss a really important meeting.
You get to work late on Friday and your self talk is Jesus.
I'm a loser,
I'm an idiot.
I'm such a loser.
That shame.
If you get to work on Friday,
same scenario area and your self talk is,
dude,
I cannot believe I did that.
That was such a lame thing to do.
That was such a stupid thing to do.
The difference is shame is a focus on cell.
Guilt is a focus on behavior.
People who are,
who are very guilt prem who say,
you know what,
I got a bad grade.
I'm not a loser,
but that was a loser idea to not study and go out last night.
They have their relationship with addiction,
depression,
violence,
suicide.
Bullying is inverse,
meaning the higher the level of guilt,
the less likely it is to experience these outcomes.
So the most dangerous,
if you look at shame and guilt and a criminal population,
the most dangerous people have the highest levels of shame proneness
and the lowest levels of guilt proneness because guilt is holding absence.
Does that make sense?
That makes perfect sense.
Yeah,
so guilt is holding up something we've done against who we want to be or
something we've done thought about doing our field to do.
I began our values,
who we want to be,
what we think is right,
and guilt is the psychological discomfort created by the cognitive dissonance
between our behavior and who we want to be and it's healthy and adaptive.
No,
it makes perfect sense.
I was having a conversation with Josh Waitzkin who's been on this podcast as
well.
He was the basis for searching for Bobby Fisher,
so he was known as a chess prodigy as a child.
He is a tremendous,
dad,
are really amazing.
Parent has it as a young boy and he has a very particular parenting style and he
always focuses on rewarding effort and not labeling his son smart.
So for instance,
he'll say that was a really good job.
You worked really hard,
you did A,
B and c that resulted in d as opposed to,
wow,
you got a great grade,
you're so smart.
Because then when the kid gets a bad grade,
it's viewed as this,
this unsolvable unfixable personal failing.
And it seems to correlate to the difference between shame.
I he,
I am flawed.
I am a broken toy that cannot be fixed versus guilt.
Like wow,
I really fucked that up bad on me,
but next time I'll do something different.
She usually he,
and the other thing is think about this as a 16 year old,
a 10 year old,
you know,
they get caught being dishonest with me and I say,
you know what?
You're a liar and you're grounded.
When you tell somebody they're a liar.
Okay,
that's a self fulfilling prophecy.
What?
What if you're,
if you're a liar,
if I Bernay brown in a liar,
what option is there for growth or change?
Okay.
That's who I am.
Right?
Not only that,
but what incentive is there not to lie if you're branded as such.
Right.
Okay.
So when you talk about the person who is thinking about committing violence or
assault on a child,
do I want that person to be more ashamed?
No,
because I have a feeling,
I mean there's,
there's,
you know,
in your example,
I guess there's pedophilia,
which can be an organic,
real issue that the majority of what we see are people who are so deeply shamed,
based,
committing horrific crimes.
So like if I thought shaming people,
no matter how hard,
I mean,
I hate to say this,
but I'll just be honest.
If I thought shaming people,
no matter how hurtful and painful it is,
if I thought that kept people safer,
I'd be all for it.
It just doesn't.
Right,
right.
Well,
it's,
you know,
it's interesting because I've been a training,
a rescue pup for the last few weeks,
a brand new rescue pup,
and she was at a kill shelter in South Carolina,
suffered a lot of abuse,
but really got into looking at a mammalian training and looking at everything
from dolphin training to polar bear training to dog training.
And the fact of the matter is,
you know,
negative reinforcement or punishment based training doesn't work that well,
or at least at the very best.
It's very slow compared to a lot of the positive reinforcement based training,
you know,
whether it's using clickers for conditioning and so on,
because you can only reinforce a behavior,
uh,
that,
that has,
that has occurred.
Right.
And when you,
I think that the,
the shame just seems to tie to me,
uh,
in an interesting way to not understanding what is malleable and what does not.
And I'd love to come back to the I am enough,
uh,
because,
in your book,
uh,
one of your several books,
but the gift of imperfection,
one of the best book titles of all time,
by the way,
so well done on that,
uh,
has been described as the lifelong journey from what will people think to I am
enough now what I'm so curious to hear about and that,
and then I'll,
I'll leap forward to daring greatly.
Uh,
and I'll just read this,
this quote,
uh,
from which I believe that the title was,
um,
was adapted.
So this is Theodore Roosevelt.
There's not the critic who counts,
not the man who points out how strong,
how the strong man stumbles or where the doer of deeds could have done them
better.
The credit belongs to the man who is actually in the arena,
whose face is marred by dust and sweat and blood,
who strives valiantly,
who at the best knows in the end of the triumph of high and who at worst,
if he fails,
at least fails while daring greatly.
Now what I have had as an internal conflict for a very long time,
and this was brought to the surface,
uh,
most noticeably at the last year and a half through meditation.
So I practice transcendental meditation in the mornings and have friends who
practice Vipassana,
transcendental different types of meditation.
And these are type a driven competitive people.
And we've,
I've had the conversation to repeatedly,
uh,
the same conversation with different people about whether that removes a
competitive edge.
And the reason being that you decide I am enough your content,
therefore you do not have discontent driving you to achieve big things that are
for most of us pretty high on Maslow's hierarchy of needs,
right?
It's like we,
we have shelter,
we have food.
So in reality,
like in almost every capacity we have enough,
we are enough.
So how do you balance the,
the,
uh,
the wellbeing of having a mindset of I am enough versus the,
at least with a lot of my,
my peers and friends in silicon valley,
the kind of discontent that seems to drive so many of those people to accomplish
great things.
Okay.
So I would go back to your really important insight from the beginning of our
conversation,
get out defining terms.
I'd also go back to kind of the insights that you're learning from doing your
training with your rescue pack,
which is does to me,
I am enough.
Okay.
I mean,
I'm a competitive type a person too.
What does that come as a surprise?
The oldest of four,
you know,
very ambitious and you know,
um,
I'm that person too in many ways.
Um,
okay.
I think the soul or the center of my ability to keep putting myself out there
and try new things even when I fail and I have had some big failures.
Um,
I think the sole goal of my healthy competitiveness and my ambition is the
belief that I am enough.
Hmm.
Um,
because I'm starting and I think what?
I don't believe I'm enough.
I engage in behaviors not to push myself,
not to grow and stretch and learn,
not to strive for excellence,
but to prove to other people what I can do.
Um,
but when I start from a place that,
you know what,
I'm enough.
I'm imperfect.
I'm afraid.
I'm,
you know,
super vulnerable,
but that does not change the fact that I'm also brave and worthy of love and
belonging.
And when I start from that place,
um,
I am completely unleashed.
So I think one of the things that's really important to help kind of define
here,
because I'm not like,
you know,
on the couch,
binge watching TV five days a week,
um,
writing nasty ass comments on other people's accomplishments,
on,
you know,
Twitter and Facebook and saying,
look like you,
I'm enough.
Like that's not what I'm talking about,
you know?
Right.
I'm talking about
I belief of self worth that
I am enough not based on what I do,
what I accomplish,
what do I,
you know,
prove are produced.
I am just enough.
And if you start from that,
that's the healthy center.
I think of most,
most of the most awesome achievements we've seen.
And I spent a lot of time in silicon valley too.
And what I can tell you,
and I know I would bet,
I wish we could have it that right now I would bet you a lot of money that if we
listed the names of 10 people,
which we're not going to do,
you could tell me which of those folks are operating and the 10,
10 competitive,
ambitious Jess law,
like crazy fighters out there in the arena.
And we listed 10 names.
You could tell me the five who are motivated from a place of being enough but
wanting to strive for excellence and learning and the five who are trying to
fill a hole and their self worth and who are dangerous.
Yeah,
no,
for sure.
And I think,
I guess the,
in my mind when I think I'm just imagining this list of 10 people in my head,
when I imagine the people who fall into the less self destructive category,
uh,
who have,
who are operating from a place of I am enough.
I guess I would in their cases say that PR in the,
if I could hear their sort of a subconscious internal mantra,
it would,
it in my mind it would seem to be,
and maybe this is the same thing,
but,
uh,
closer to I m I'm good or I'm really good,
but I can be better.
Uh,
not I am flawed.
I need to impress everyone around me to make them validate me.
Um,
but the,
I guess I'm just struggling with the word enough,
but I,
I understand the,
the point of it.
Um,
and I think it's [inaudible] this is something that I struggle with,
right?
I mean,
I'm the extremely,
personally,
I'm very hard on myself.
I mean,
I've always sort of been of the mindset that,
you know,
second place is first loser and extremely competitive,
uh,
in that is not always been the healthiest thing for,
me and all sorts of different capacities.
Um,
but I don't the,
let's,
let's sort of tackle this from a slightly different angle.
So the,
the daring greatly,
uh,
the question that,
I think is raised in that,
that book among others is heavy.
You dared greatly today.
And a please feel free to take this in any direction,
uh,
because I,
you obviously know more about your work than I do,
but how,
what is a good way to evaluate that?
And do you ask yourself this type of question on a daily basis?
Do you have,
uh,
um,
I'll leave it at that.
I could,
I could make this a 12 part question,
but how does someone determine if they've dared greatly and is,
how often would you suggest someone kind of check in and ask themselves that?
So I think for me,
daring greatly,
and you know,
that that quote from Theodore Roosevelt,
um,
I even got teary eyed while you were reading it.
Um,
you know,
it was a life changer for me.
Um,
it was right after the Tedx Houston talk had gone viral.
I was kind of everywhere on the Internet at that time.
And you know,
everyone,
you know,
ABC,
CBS,
NBC,
Fox,
having imposed were all writing about this.
Who is this person at the University of Houston with this Ted talk going viral
and as we could ever imagine.
And um,
all these online stories had online comments that are of course like,
yeah.
And so my husband and my therapist were like,
don't read the comments.
Um,
and so I read all the comments one day and yeah,
I really,
I sit down and just read them for like an hour.
And I think,
you know,
if you ask,
if you're listening to the,
I could hear listener right now,
you know,
if you close your eyes and think about
we all have the shame triggers,
we all have two or three things.
We are,
most of us have more that you could overhear somebody,
you could overhear someone saying about you that would be sick,
so painful and so hurtful that you don't know if you could survive it.
Most of us have those things.
And so for me,
up until that point,
you know,
I,
those things really dictated my life.
I was like,
look,
I'm going to engineer this career to kind of be small and safe.
I'm going to play right under the radar because I am not willing to put myself
out there and get criticized.
Like I know it was happening.
And so the problem with staying small,
um,
is it always served up with resentment and pissed off at us.
Um,
because we're not using,
our guests were not in our power and there's always a price for that.
Right.
And so to me,
when I read that quote,
you know,
and when I looked to the comments,
they were things like,
of course she,
you know,
of course she embraces imperfection.
What choice would you have if you look like her?
I feel sorry for her husband and kids.
More Botox,
less research.
You need to shake loose pounds before you talk about being worthy.
I mean,
just like really shitty,
hurtful stuff.
Um,
and then I came on,
I came upon that.
I mean,
like the next 30 minutes after reading all that,
I came upon that comment.
I mean,
that quote from Theodore reason about,
and you know,
in that moment what I realized is,
you know what,
I do want to live a brave life.
I do want to live in the arena.
And if you're going to live in the arena,
the only guarantee is you will get your ass kicked.
Um,
and the second thing is that daring greatly is being vulnerable.
So when you ask yourself,
did I dare greatly today,
the big question I ask is,
did I,
when I had the opportunity,
did I choose courage over comfort?
You know,
when things went sideways between Steve and I this morning over,
you know,
who was going to pack a lunch for my son?
Did I just go into the old pattern of rolling my eyes and walk out of the
kitchen or did I choose courage and say,
I'm sorry,
I'm feeling really overwhelmed with the book launch tomorrow.
And um,
I'm sorry,
I really apologize.
That was hurtful to I choose courage or that she's comfort.
And so to me that's the question we ask,
um,
about daring greatly.
And I think,
you know,
I think one of the things that you said 10 really when you're talking about your
friends and this idea of being enough,
one of the things that really turned my life upside down,
there were four or five things in the research that have taken me a long time to
get over and get through.
And one of them was the difference between healthy striving or striving for
excellence and perfectionism.
And
I've always been perfectionistic about my stuff and what I learned in the
research was that perfectionism is very outwardly defined.
It's dictated by what will people think and healthy striving is dictated.
Our striving for excellence is internally motivated.
And so perfectionism is really,
I call it the 20 ton shield and I think a lot of them were talking about those
10 people,
five of whom work from this place of wholeness.
And the other,
I think what a lot of times we're talking about is the difference between
perfectionism and striving for excellence.
And I think perfectionism is this 20 ton shield that we carry around.
And it's a defense mechanism classically that just says,
if I live perfect love,
perfect work,
perfect and accomplished perfectly,
I can reduce or minimize shame,
blame,
criticism and judgment.
And so we carry this thing around.
I'm thinking it's protecting us,
but what it's really doing is keeping us from being seen.
And so I think when I asked myself personally,
have I dared greatly today,
sometimes for me it is the question of
was I enough or am I trying to get everything perfect so that I can somehow
think I'm mitigating criticism and judgment.
Right?
Well,
I also find,
and I haven't really thought about it in these terms before,
but if you look at say,
I think it's Barry Schwartz,
the paradox of choice where he talks about,
um,
maximizers and s I think it's satisfying answers.
Uh,
but if I try to correlate that to my own experience being I think very much a
perfectionist and that,
uh,
of my,
my friends,
um,
the,
the people who are perfectionists,
um,
very often are so future focused that the perfection once achieved is viewed as
the trigger.
That wall sort of solve their guilt,
shame,
discontent,
et Cetera.
Whereas the,
uh,
the people who are striving for excellence,
excellence are better at celebrating the little wins,
accepting the small defeats and sometimes the large defeats a and tend to be a
bit more present,
state focused.
And you mentioned you to vulnerability,
uh,
and you and the sort of components,
right?
So you're facing whether it's an uncertainty risk and so on.
Um,
and I,
I've seen it described elsewhere as,
you know,
stopping,
controlling and predicting,
uh,
the,
it seems very much akin to certain tenants and say,
stoic philosophy,
uh,
of which I read a lot.
Uh,
whether it's mark is really us or Seneca,
et cetera.
And then there are a lot of common threads in Buddhism,
of course,
that would,
um,
talk about health,
how fruitless it is and few tile.
It is to try to eliminate suffering a completely,
because we are almost by definition,
experiencers of suffering.
Right.
And coming to terms with that,
what's,
uh,
which,
which thinkers,
philosophers or schools of thinking or philosophy most resonate with the
insights you found in the data,
in your research?
Ah,
my God.
He,
all of the above,
like,
I mean it took me,
it took me probably Marcus Aurelius to Liberation Theology,
Liberation Theology.
Oh,
uh,
at,
it's a Catholic,
um,
kind of,
uh,
Catholic theology of social justice and that has,
it's had its stronghold and beginning in Central America.
But I mean,
I think it has just one of the things about being a grounded theory researcher
that I love and hate is we don't start with an existing theory and then go try
to prove or disprove it.
We build a theory from people's lived experiences and then we do the literature
review and see where it fits and where it doesn't fit.
Because the idea between behind grounded theory is if you start with a,
an existing theory,
you're just kind of paying homage to,
they would say the theoretical capitalist that came before you and that it's
people's lived experiences that really matter.
Insta people often comment and my books do,
like how is it that you're quoting?
I do put Marcus Aurelius,
I think in one of my books,
how are you quoting him?
And then how are you quoting Pema Chodron,
who is an American Buddhist nun,
right?
And then you're quoting Disney Pixar movie from toy story.
And to me,
I have no division and very little tolerance for like the highbrow versus low
brow inspiration.
Um,
I think if you're paying attention you can find truth and inspiration anywhere
and everywhere.
Um,
and so to me,
I'm all over the place and the literature and I,
I think that people who really depend on polarity will hate this,
but really some very strong common themes are across Christianity,
Buddhism,
Judaism,
you know,
as long.
MMM.
Joseph Campbell.
I mean,
I think
I ended up finding myself
in some just profound truths from a lot of,
I mean,
I was reading something yesterday,
I'm in the data and it made me pull out my book by Kabran,
so I think it's Roomy,
Mary,
Mary Oliver,
Neil Peart,
the drummer for rush,
like I was,
something came up and I was like,
yeah,
I was like,
I didn't know if you knew.
So I had to put it in there.
But,
um,
I was like,
this is when you choose,
when you choose,
when you don't make a choice,
when you choose not to decide,
you still have made a choice.
And I think,
I don't know that anyone says it more eloquently than rush,
you know?
I don't know what to say.
Right,
Neil?
Yeah.
Just as a side note,
if people want to see just a beast of a drummer than you can,
you can search on youtube for some videos.
This guy,
oh my goodness,
what a monster on the kit,
but,
and appellate,
you know,
so I find my inspiration kind of everywhere.
And,
uh,
let's,
let's talk about misinterpretations of vulnerability for a second.
And I think maybe I'm getting a little,
I'm probably projecting my own prejudices here,
but,
um,
is it vulnerability there?
I think there's some people who misinterpret being vulnerable and the benefits
derived from being vulnerable with,
uh,
incessant oversharing of emotions or inner dialogue or doubt.
Um,
what would you say to those?
What would you say to those people?
Maybe my diagnosis is off,
off base,
but there's some,
there are a lot of people who just kind of pour out every concern,
worry,
fault,
mistake,
uh,
and,
um,
okay.
It with the,
the label of vulnerability.
Um,
so I'd just love to hear your thoughts on that.
A word salad that I just dropped on you.
I love it.
I'm tracking 100% because I,
yeah,
it's,
there's a very simple formula in my head.
Vulnerability minus boundaries is not vulnerability.
It can be desperation.
It can be oversharing,
it can be manipulation.
It can be a lot of different things,
but it's not vulnerability.
Um,
we always have to hold awareness of boundaries and roles in our minds around
vulnerability.
We share with people who've earned the right to hear our story and we stay
mindful all the time of the role we're at.
And so one of the great examples I can give you is I'm with 50 CEOs from Silicon
Valley and we've spent a long weekend together.
And toward the end of maybe the first day one of them says,
I came here thinking that I would never,
you know,
believe in vulnerability are accepted,
but I am 100% on board.
So I want to make sure I understand that I should stand up in front of,
you know,
my investors,
my vcs,
and you know,
and say,
look,
I am in over my head.
We are bleeding money and I do not know what to do next.
Right?
And I said,
you know,
only if you don't want another round of funding,
should you do that?
I mean,
no,
that's,
that's super,
that's not appropriate.
But let me,
you know,
let me ask you this.
If you had,
you know,
if you had,
I don't know,
$50,000 invested with this leader,
wouldn't you be praying to God that he's sitting across from someone saying
that?
Sure,
definitely hunter.
Right,
right.
I don't care if it's,
whether it's his therapist and mentor and advisor because what the,
what the alternative is if he's really drowning in a river,
has had and bleeding money and doesn't know what he's doing is to just keep
grinding harder and harder on the same things he's doing
and not ask for help.
Right,
right.
Totally.
Yeah.
And so when people say,
you know,
live tweeting your bikini wax,
that is not vulnerability.
Sorry about that.
It was only once.
Yeah.
I mean,
if,
so,
if you could hold back a little bit,
10 we'd really all appreciate it.
Um,
no,
or sharing intimate details of your children's reaction to your impending
divorce on Facebook.
That is not vulnerability.
Vulnerability is the birthplace of intimacy,
trust,
connection,
creativity and innovation for leaders.
It's the birthplace of trusted.
Um,
but it's not permission to overshare.
Right,
right.
Well,
I mean,
the,
the investor example is great because the,
if a,
if a CEO or founder gets up and says,
it provides the confession that you give us an example in front of a room that
will almost inevitably respond by say,
Yanking,
um,
funding.
It's not a,
it's not a constructive use of that confession,
if that makes sense.
Um,
and it's,
I live in San Francisco most of the time and it's,
it's this,
this sort of,
this,
uh,
misinterpretations of vulnerability is oversharing,
is very common among the kind of burning man,
a spiritual atheist sect.
Uh,
and it's,
I think it's massively problematic.
I think it creates,
uh,
it's,
it appears to create many more problems than it solves a,
and,
um,
the,
let me use that as a segue.
So the,
the opposite.
I was interviewing a well known strength coach named Pavel Tsatsouline was
originally from,
I think the run the Ukraine,
um,
nitty case,
former Soviet Union.
And I,
one of the questions I asked him on the podcast was,
what,
uh,
in your book,
what do you write in your personal journal that you don't often talk about with
other people?
And his head's there was,
well,
Tim,
that is a very personal question.
And he proceeded to tell him
and he proceeded to tell me that,
you know,
oversharing is,
is a big problem in the United States.
And I was like,
well,
you know,
that's actually,
I feel like that's a fair response.
And so I wanted to ask you a question that's based on input from a number of
listeners of this podcast and the here's the lead.
And I'd be very curious to hear your thoughts.
So
there's lots of chatter about over feminization of boys.
Um,
how do you,
uh,
how do you have vulnerability coexist with strong masculine virtues slash
traits?
And I'm paraphrasing here and I'll just give another sort of contextual example
that a mayor,
and it may or may not be interesting to comment on.
So there's an expression in some military training that is suffer in silence.
And the idea is if you're going through hell week for the navy seals or
something like that,
and you're carrying logs around and laying down in the freezing cold water,
climbing under barbed wire,
doing all of these just nausea and fear inducing things.
If you complain like,
my foot hurts,
this,
that,
and the other thing,
it will trigger more suffering in the people around you.
Um,
which I happen to agree with in that context.
so that's a lot at once,
but,
um,
what did,
what is your thinking on the,
uh,
the,
the so called sort of over a feminization of boys and masculine virtues slash
traits versus vulnerability?
I mean,
how,
how do they coexist?
Um,
and maybe that's not even the right question.
It's a really good question.
And I,
I,
you know,
I work a lot with special horses,
um,
and with the military and,
uh,
and with that,
yeah.
May I add one more thing?
Just,
yeah.
Just so that I'm,
I'm not,
I people don't think I'm representing only the male side of this.
Yeah.
A lot of my female friends,
um,
complained to me that,
okay,
in a lot of urban centers in the u s San Francisco,
et Cetera,
they can only find guys to date and they're looking for men to date.
So it's not just this is,
this is a concern,
not just from the male side.
It seems to be coming from both sides.
So,
sorry to interrupt,
but I just wanted to throw,
no,
I think it's really important.
So I have so much to say on it that overwhelmed.
I don't even know where to start,
so I'm going to just try to,
I am,
I'm just like busting.
I've got over here.
Um,
okay.
So
these binaries,
uh,
you know,
tough and tender,
masculine,
feminine,
you know,
I think we have to be really careful about this because if we,
when we start to talk about vulnerable to talk about,
and in the context of my work,
you've gotten really wrong.
I'm like,
okay.
Um,
if you talk about vulnerability
and vulnerability to me is courage.
And so when I,
when I hear women talk about their inability to be with the vulnerable man,
it's,
it makes tons of sense to me because,
you know,
I wish I could say,
I think number one perpetrator of shame with men.
We're all those,
you know,
shitty dads and terrible coaches and those buddies.
But the number one perpetrator of shame with men is women.
Um,
and so I often say,
show me a woman who can sit with a man in real fear and vulnerability.
I will show you a woman who's done her own work around vulnerability and doesn't
derive her power or status from that man.
You show me a man who can sit with a woman who's in real fear and vulnerability.
And I'll show you a man who's done his own work around vulnerability and doesn't
derive his power from being Oz.
The all knowing and all fixing.
Because what men have a tendency to do when we're feeling vulnerable are afraid,
is try to fix it because it's how we're socialized.
And so I think when you talk about how we're raising boys today,
okay,
here's what I can tell you from 150,000 pieces of data looking back,
um,
from what I've learned from men,
the men who were raised to be open and feeling and tender and loving and given
no skills and no information on how to navigate boy culture and male culture do
not do well,
right?
The boys who were raised on how to navigate male culture,
King of the hill and had no tools on how to be open and vulnerable and
emotionally available do worse,
but they also don't do well.
So it's about we need to stop with these fall separations between tough and
tender.
You know,
toughen,
Tinder can coexist.
Um,
and to me that's kind of this,
that's kind of the equation for Badass or it.
Um,
and it can also exist in women like,
you know,
Grit and grace,
tough and tender,
afraid and brave.
You know,
this idea that we're either courageous or,
or chicken shit
okay.
Is just not true because most of us are afraid and braid at the exact same
moment all day long.
And so to take courage and vulnerability to,
to not teach that to our kids,
boys or girls
is not teaching them how to be emotionally available or Tinder either.
Right?
And so I think what concerns me is it about the need to drive a stake through
the middle of these things.
Um,
and I think that's what's really important.
I mean to be both.
Yeah.
No,
I,
and I agree with you.
I mean,
I think that they're not Benchley exclusive.
There's no need for a false dichotomy.
It's,
um,
I think a lot of it comes back to sort of choosing the appropriate environment
for expressing that vulnerability,
if that makes sense.
It's a,
it's a toughie.
It seems,
it seems tough.
I mean,
I,
uh,
because you find men who have the armor plating on it and can never take it off
that for what it's worth,
the guys I've met who are operating at the highest level in say special forces
do not have that problem.
Um,
they are,
they,
they tend not to suffer from a lot of PTSD,
for instance.
And they are very empathetic and emotionally attuned for them,
at least in this subset of folks that I've met.
Um,
but they've,
they've been subjected to just insane amounts of abuse and conditioning to,
for mental and physical toughness.
But at the same time I see them playing with their kids or with their wives and
they're extremely present.
So that's,
but that's,
it's a tough needle to thread
as it can't be coming.
So speaking of just the challenges that people have with safe vulnerability,
what are some daily practices or exercises that people can,
um,
contest to help them develop more vulnerability,
less shame,
et cetera?
You know,
I think it's interesting that you talk about,
you know,
daily practices because I think vulnerability is a daily practice.
And for a lot of us,
you know,
at least for me when it,
when it was new,
it was about trying on new ways of being and kind of testing it out.
And one of the things that emerged from the data is this,
this idea of trust and the relationship between trust and vulnerability.
And people always ask me,
you gain trust first and then you're vulnerable with people.
Um,
but the truth is you can't really earn trust over time with people without being
somewhat vulnerable.
So it's a little bit of a back and forth.
It's a little bit of,
um,
sharing things that are maybe not super deeply personal,
but are meaningful to you and seeing how that feels to share them and be open.
One thing that you said that I've never thought about it until this interview,
but it was such a remarkable,
um,
insight from you.
Did I want to go back to when you talk about daily practice is when you were
talking about perfectionism being future focused,
um,
and also kind of presenting some struggles about staying in the now.
I think that's why,
and again,
I'm just putting this insight together,
your insight.
I think that's why a lot of people who are that Super Uber Competitive,
um,
high,
strong,
overachieving,
don't get the same results in their personal lives with their partners and their
children as they do in their professional kind of endeavors or their
recreational endeavors.
Because our personal relationships with the people we love,
those intimate relationships require a presence,
a focus on now that a lot of times professional success does not depend on that.
Yes,
very true.
Yeah,
You can fly fast and if,
you know,
if you're in a little hole Cessna two seater,
you got to,
you know,
you're in the here and now and you got to pay attention to every bump and every
gauge and pay,
you know.
But if you're in a jet,
you can't afford to be thinking about now.
You have to be thinking about five minutes from now.
Um,
and so I thought it was a really remarkable and on your part because what I do
think about those 10 friends and Silicon Valley or I think about my own life
even I think what the research has changed most is it,
I think it has had a huge impact on my professional success,
but more than anything when I get home,
um,
I walk into a marriage and her relationship with kids that is fun,
that are fundamentally different than they were before I became okay with
vulnerability and okay with less than perfect.
But what does the first 60 to 90 days of a upset of 60,
90 days,
60 to 90 minutes of your day look like your morning routines or rituals outside
of book launch times and things like that.
Let's just assume that you have control of your,
your optimal day,
but what is the first,
uh,
what are your morning rituals look like?
What does your,
your first 60 to 90 minutes look like?
I wake up,
um,
what time do you wake up?
Six 30.
I wake out,
I um,
do a lot of deep breathing to stay at off an absolute desperate need for a head
of data,
um,
from my phone or from my computer.
So I tried very hard not to check email or texts cause I don't,
I sleep with my phone downstairs and I'll sleep with any kind of computer next
to me.
Um,
and then,
you know,
it's really super normal.
I wake up kids,
I make breakfast,
I pack lunches,
I go through the calendar with the day I zip up backpacks,
I drive carpool.
Um,
I usually get from Carpool pool to swim.
I'm a swimmer,
a swimmer,
so I like to swim and I swim and walk,
um,
as plumbing is kind of the Trifecta for me.
It's not a meditation exercise and there'll be right.
And then I usually start my day,
my work day.
And what time,
what time,
what time do you finish swimming and how long has the swim session?
Um,
if,
if I rent,
my best case scenario is I run and swam.
And so I don't swim fast enough anymore.
A slim tight at times for many more like,
you know,
fifties on every 20 or anything like I used to.
So it's more,
it's not as cardio is it used to be.
Um,
so I like to run on the treadmill for 30 minutes and then I like to swim for
half an hour.
Got It.
And if I was a bike rider,
I could be a triathlete,
but the bag,
the,
I tried it once and the bike going that fast next to that many people going that
fast is really uncomfortable for me.
Yeah,
I'd imagine it.
So I'm a,
I'm a do athlete.
Slow.
Do,
um,
what,
what book besides your own,
have you gifted to other people?
Most,
but we're,
what book do you have you often given as a gift?
Oh
Man.
I have given so many copies of the outcomist two people that I should get a
little royalty on it.
Yeah,
that's a great book.
That's a great book.
Uh,
speaking of books,
so you have a new book out,
rising strong.
And it seems to me like this
completes a trilogy in a sense.
It seems like the three books go together very well,
but could you give people a description of the latest book and why you wrote it?
Okay.
Yeah,
sure.
Um,
I think they do go together and I don't,
I wasn't intentional on that,
but I think the gifts is bu daring greatly as be all n and this book is,
it's your ass kicked to get up and do it again.
Um,
this is about,
okay,
just the physics of vulnerability.
You know,
if you're brave enough option math,
you're going to fall,
you're going to experience heartbreak,
disappointment,
failure.
It's going to happen.
And so going into this research,
the question for me was what do men and women who experienced falls and get back
up and are even more courageous and more tenacious?
What do they have in common?
So rising strong is about the process that emerged from that question.
And uh,
can you describe your,
your research method?
How do you find your interviewees?
Um,
what is the sort of interview format look like?
A,
what do you do with the data afterwards,
et Cetera.
About 70% of my interviews are individuals.
And more focus groups in the last data set.
And so some of them,
like for example,
I went to West Point and sat down with,
I think there were six officers who had all come back from active.
Yeah.
Combat duty.
So sometimes I'll do focus groups and,
but the majority of them are individuals.
A lot of it is snowball sampling.
Meaning I've interviewed you 10 and I'm like,
you know what,
I'm really,
this is really helpful.
I would love to interview some of the folks that you know,
in Silicon Valley around perfectionism.
Um,
would you mind doing a warm introduction?
Right?
Um,
and some of them are just kind of calls like this.
This book is a lot about the power of story and the stories we tell ourselves.
So I interviewed Shonda Rhimes,
the show runner for scandal.
And um,
and so,
so some emerges,
you know,
it's a lot easier to get people now that it was when I first started and I was
like,
hi,
my name's per day and I would like to talk to you about shame.
But,
but now it's more that,
you know,
I can now,
I just do mostly individual and in focus groups.
And so then I get the data.
I A,
we don't record it.
I take what we call and the field anthropological field nuts.
So I capture exact phrases and sentences during our interview.
Um,
I let participants look at them if they want you when they're done.
Some say yes,
some say no.
And then I code what I learned against what I already know that for patterns and
saturation in the data.
Meaning if I am trying to study perfectionism and entrepreneurs in silicon
valley,
I'll start interviewing them and I'll know that I've reached saturation,
what I can predict,
what the next person's going to say.
Because one of the really tough rules of grounded theory research are we don't
allow for any outliers.
And so if I'm almost done and then I sit down with you and you say something and
does it fit with the theory that I'm developing in my head about what's
happening,
then I have to go back to the drawing board and keep interviewing because every
lived experience is real matters,
right?
So it would be like interviewing a hundred people in Silicon Valley.
We're saying they're trying to democratize pizza,
ordering,
democratize a kitty litter delivery,
democratize this.
And then someone said,
I'm really looking to establish a silo of command and control,
like in North Korean dictator for X.
And he'd be like,
ugh.
All right,
well then I have to keep,
yeah.
If that happened,
then I have to question what I'm hearing.
I have to question what I'm hearing from the Kitty Litter and the other folks.
Right?
And I have to figure out what,
what do y'all meaning,
what are y'all meaningfully say in co have in common?
And uh,
it,
I mean it's,
it seems to me you're rising strong,
uh,
is
it's a must have not a nice to have.
Right?
And I'm not saying that the be yourself dare greatly are nice to haves,
but if you don't have the resilience to recover from mistakes,
you're never going to dare greatly in the first place in,
in,
in some respect it would seem right.
So if you,
if would you recommend,
what order would you recommend people read your books in?
I mean understanding that this is the latest of course,
but what,
what sort of,
uh,
the ideal sequence?
Yeah,
I think,
you know,
they go together,
but they don't,
I mean,
I think they can each be read independently.
So I think sometimes it's helpful to pick up the book based on where you are.
If you're really struggling with the hustle,
hustling for perfection and hustle and you know,
proving and perfecting and pretending.
I think the gifts is great.
If you really are,
you know,
are the rest of us sick and tired of being afraid and you want to be braid and
you want to feel like,
what does that look like?
I think daring greatly is,
or is this place to start?
And if you find yourself face down in the arena and you're thinking,
God,
I just got my ass handed to me,
I think,
I think strong would be a good place to start.
It probably makes sense.
You know,
there's a sequence.
So I think if you're just like,
wow,
I'm interested,
I would start with your and great.
I mean,
uh,
the guests.
But I think I also think for your audience,
it's probably helpful to know that I spent the last couple of years exclusively
working with leaders and entrepreneurs.
So daring greatly and rising strong have much more of my research from
organizations and from leaders that in the gifts does.
Got It.
No,
that is helpful.
Uh,
just a few more questions and then we're coming up on time.
So I'll ask just a couple of rapid fire questions,
but the answers don't have to be rapid.
Um,
and I'm,
I'm very curious about this one.
When you think of the word successful,
who is the first person who comes to mind for you and why?
You know,
what's so weird?
I don't picture anybody.
I,
I picture the word redefine that.
That is such a,
that has been such a dangerous word in my research.
The word successful.
Yup.
Our success.
I agree that I don't even use it anymore because what does that mean?
Like,
okay,
so I am the CEO of this company.
I make a shit ton of money.
This is my title.
This is the influence and power I have.
I'm on my fourth marriage and their relationship with my adult children.
Right.
So I,
I think what I hear the word successful and my answer is be clear that your
ladder is leaning against the right building,
right?
Yeah.
Bad word.
Next question.
Yeah.
I Dunno why.
No,
no,
I,
I agree with you.
I think happiness is actually really similar.
Oh yes.
That's a,
that's a scary,
nebulous,
dangerous term as well.
Uh,
what $100 or less purchase has most positively impacted your life in recent
memory?
Oh,
a triathalon goggles because I don't know if for some reason they're softer and
so that I don't have goggle marks all day.
Oh,
really?
I had no idea what a,
what do you know the brand of goggles off?
I don't,
but they're like the most famous triathalon Ba and they're really patty and you
look like we all like swam with a speedo.
Vanquisher like little the goggles.
Sure.
That makes for a bad ass.
Um,
and the bigger your dog will the goofier you were,
but now it's time for the goofy Goggle for me.
Yeah.
I really like the aqua sphere.
Cayman Goggles,
k a I m a n and Laird Hamilton is this big wave surfer.
Yeah.
Uses,
uh,
I will look them up.
Goggles.
I just put them for those people interested in it,
put them in my latest,
uh,
five bullet Friday.
You can just search my name and five bullet Fridays.
But um,
yeah,
it does seem like the bigger goggles coming back.
Uh,
if,
if you could have one billboard anywhere with anything on it,
what would it say in,
where would you put it?
Yeah,
I would put it in Washington DC
and it would say,
shut up and listen.
That's great.
That's great that that can be put anywhere.
I would love to put that on,
uh,
on the,
on the highway highway one on one to two 80 in silicon valley to cause men or
men or people talking a lot these days and pitching,
pitching really hard without asking many good questions.
You know what?
I wouldn't say shut up cause my kids would be like,
oh my God,
we're not even allowed to say that word.
So I would say talk less.
Listen more.
But I in my heart I'd be saying shut up.
Yeah.
We could split test.
It could,
it could be that,
that could be the Hashtag.
Yeah.
Just shut your face.
Uh,
what advice would you give your 30 year old self?
It's okay to be afraid.
You don't have to be so scary when you're scared.
Huh?
Meaning what?
Put on put on airs of confidence and
yes.
Yes.
Like the thirties or so exhausting.
It's like,
yeah,
it is at the age of perfecting,
proving,
pretending.
Um,
and there's some liberation that can't.
Yeah.
For me that came in my fourth.
There was a breakdown of course,
but it followed by some liberation that came in my forties.
So I would just say,
you know,
every,
stop hustling.
Right?
Yeah.
The uh,
you mentioned the breakdown,
the,
the breakthrough disguise a breakdown.
Uh,
did she say to your 30 year old self,
okay,
start meditating and show the fuck out.
That's,
you don't need to,
you don't need to have resting pulse of 150 beats per minute to get a lot of big
things done.
There's similar messages.
Right?
Yeah,
very similar.
I think that,
well,
I think it's very easy for people,
and I'm sure I still do this,
but to mistake the symptoms of success with the things that cause success,
they're not the same.
Right.
Yeah.
Uh,
do you have any ask or request for all of the people listening?
of course I would highly recommend that they check out your work,
including rising strong,
the latest book,
which I will link to in the show notes for everybody,
but any other ask request or recommendation for everybody listening?
I would just say keep being part of the conversation about these tougher,
about these type of topics,
about vulnerability,
about shame,
about being brave.
I'm just
lean into some discomfort because I think these,
what's the seemingly impossible problems that we have around race and homophobia
and the environment.
Um,
and just the lack of love sometimes are not going to be solved an uncomfortable
way.
We can't,
we've got to,
you know,
you have to choose comfort or courage.
You just can't have both.
So I guess my ask would be more of a,
a big metaphysical ask that,
um,
give vulnerability a shot,
you know,
and give discomfort.
It's due because I think there is a really strong relationship between your
willingness.
He or she,
who's willing to be the most uncomfortable is not only the bravest but rises the
fastest.
Totally agree.
Well,
I think the,
the only,
the only way to ensure long term comfort is to have continual short term
discomfort.
Yeah.
Well this has been a blast.
Bernay where can people say hello to you online?
Where can they find out more about you?
Find you on the social networks?
Okay.
Yeah.
Um,
I am at an APP Bernay Brown on Twitter and Instagram and Bernay Brown on
Facebook.
Um,
we just launched a new project that we're excited about called courage works,
um,
which is bringing all of my teachings to online,
for individuals and leaders in organizations.
And that's just courage work,
stop,
calm.
Um,
and so I'm at,
I'm in all those places.
Well I,
I enjoy your work.
I appreciate your work and thank you so much for taking the time folks
listening.
You can find links to everything that we discussed,
show notes,
et
cetera@fourhourworkweekdotcomandjustclickonpodcastallspelledoutforourworkweek.com
and please say hello to Bernay on the interwebs and join the conversation.
I'll also have a question of the day in the blog posts that you guys can
continue this conversation as Bernay suggested,
but uh,
Pernay thank you so much for making the time.
It was awesome.
Thank you so much Tim.
I appreciate it.
And everybody listening.
As always,
thank you for listening and until next day,
until the next day,
until next time to needs more caffeine.
Put Aviva and face your discomfort.
Practice discomfort.
Thanks for listening.
This episode is brought to you by wealth front and this is a very unique
sponsor.
Wealthfront is a massively disruptive in a good way.
Set it and forget it.
Investing service led by technologists from places like apple and world famous
investors.
It has exploded in popularity in the last two years and they now have more than
two and a half billion dollars under management.
In fact,
some of my very good friends,
investors in silicon valley have millions of their own money in Wealthfront.
So the question is why?
Why is it so popular?
Why is it unique?
Because you can get services previously reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them.
And this is because they use smarter software instead of retail locations,
bloated sales teams,
et cetera.
And I'll come back to that in a second.
I suggest you check out wealthfront.com forward slash Tim take the risk
assessment quiz which only takes two to five minutes and they'll show you for
free exactly the portfolio they'd put you in and if you just want to take their
advice,
run with it,
do it yourself.
You can do that or as I would,
you can set it and forget it.
Here's why.
The value of Wealthfront is in the automation of habits and strategies that
investors should be using on a regular basis but normally aren't.
Great investing is a marathon,
not a sprint,
and little things that you may or may not be familiar with like automatic tax
loss harvesting,
rebalancing your portfolio,
cross more than 10 asset classes and dividend reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods of time.
Wealthfront,
as I mentioned,
since it's using software instead of retail locations,
etc. Can offer all of this at low costs that were previously completely
impossible right off the bat,
you never pay commissions or account fees for everything.
They charge 0.25% per year on assets above the first 15,000 which is managed for
free.
If you use my link,
wealthfront.com forward slash Tim,
that is less than $5 a month to invest a $30,000 account for instance.
Now,
normally when I have a sponsor on the show,
it's because I use them and recommend them.
In this case,
it's a little different.
I don't use Wealthfront yet because I'm not allowed to.
Here's the deal.
They wanted to sponsor this podcast,
but because of SCC regulations,
companies that invest your money are not allowed to use client testimonials,
so I couldn't be a user end have them on the podcast,
but I've been so impressed by Wealthfront that I've invested a significant
amount of my own money,
at least for me in the team and the company itself.
So I am an investor and hope to soon use it as a client.
Now back to the recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show listener,
you'll get $15,000 managed for free if you decide to open an account,
but just start with seeing the portfolio that they would suggest for you.
Take two minutes,
fill out their questionnaire@wealthfront.com forward slash.
Tim It's fast,
it's free.
There's no downside that I can think of.
Now I do have to read a mandatory disclaimer.
Wealthfront Inc is an SEC registered investment advisor.
Investing in securities involves risks and there is the possibility of losing
money.
Past performance is no guarantee of future results.
Please visit wealthfront.com to read their full disclosure,
so check it out.
Guys.
This is one of the hottest,
most innovative companies coming out of Silicon Valley and they're killing it.
They've become massively popular.
Just take a look,
see what portfolio they would create for you,
and you can use that information however you want.
wealthfront.com forward slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by Vimeo pro,
which is the ideal video hosting platform for entrepreneurs and in fact a bunch
of my startups already use Vimeo pro including wealth front who uses it to
explain how wealth front works task grab,
it uses it to tell the company story and there are many other names you would
recognize among their customers,
airbnb,
Etsy,
et cetera.
Why do they use it?
Well,
Vimeo pro provides enterprise level video hosting for a fraction of the usual
cost.
Features include gorgeous high quality playback with no ads,
up to 20 gigabytes of video storage every week.
Unlimited plays in views and they fully customizable video player,
which can include your logo,
custom outro,
et cetera.
You also get VIP support and you get all of this for just one 99 per year.
That's $17 a month with no complicated bandwidth calculations or hidden fees and
you can try it risk free for 30 days.
So check it out.
[inaudible] dot com forward slash business.
That's v I n e o.com forward slash business and use Promo Code Tim to get 25%
off.
That's a special discount just for you guys.
So check it out.
demio.com forward slash business promo code.
Tim,
and until next time,
thank you for listening.
Yeah.
Okay.